bonjour mes amis
je ne fais que passer j'ai décidé de
passer la journée tout seul dans mon
grenier parce qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai
rien envie de faire et j'aime beaucoup
françois julie et monsieur dit stop mais
depuis quelques temps je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont chaque fois que je les vois
il me donne un travail à faire est
vraiment aujourd'hui je ne veux rien
créer un alors si vous les voyez vous ne
leur dit rien
revoir je vais passer la journée dans
mon grenier
[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour julie tu n'aurais pas vu casimir
aujourd'hui par hasard ah non je n'ai
pas vu non et bien tant pis je vais
m'occuper tout seul de mes balles au mid
enfants vous n'avez pas vu kazemi
c'est ennuyeux je voulais justement lui
demandé de ranger mon kiosque plus que
chers amis contre mes salutations
distinguées
l'ouvragé aussi du snav avez vous vu
casimir
non je n'ai pas vu à fait dommage
j'avais justement un service à lui
demander
j'ai un gros cactus à accroche pour dans
mon jardin
mais alors si tout le monde cherche
casimir et personne ne le trouve c'est
que il a disparu
je n'en suis pas persuadé en tout cas il
faut faire quelque chose moi je suis
inquiète il faut qu'on le retrouve tout
de suite attendez si on demander aux
grands détectives merlotte folle mais ce
peu ce qui pourrait nous aider lui est
une très bonne idée monsieur 10,9
et givet julie car moi je crois savoir
comme retrouver quasi nulles à toute
assez incroyable que je connaisse tous
les grands de ce monde et que je ne
connaisse pas ceux qui mélangent paul
vous allez voir il est extraordinaire il
retrouve tout ce qui disparaît mais
c'est inquiétant ce que vous dites là ma
chère amie serait-il aussi génial que
moi
certainement
mais c'est à peine croyable
c'est même incroyable
incroyable
mon enfant réveillez-vous secours est
beau il est impensable que ce monsieur
fall mais ce sont ces géniales que moi
et
tu
es le messie ni comment ses potes le
bullage et bien pas très bien monsieur
fun mais vous savez que je sais casimir
a disparu je sais tout n'est je sais que
ce grand monsieur rigolo là bas c'est le
facteur va pas du tout le facteur je me
présente fulbert en scène du snob
président de la fed et les enfants
président du club philatélique de la
chorale les amis du cirque et théâtre en
élytre et nancray crise nous devons être
animés
en effet il fait tout pour
guillaume mulak géométrie siens mais
l'iphone est tu m'avais détective du
monde nous confondre avec le fact allons
voyons le chai du snob monsieur phal
metz voulait plaisanté fait la paix
je veux bien mais à une condition
qu'il retrouve casimir dans les cinq
minutes qui suivent c'est comme si cela
était déjà fait je retrouve tout ce qui
se voit tout ce qui se reniflent de ceux
qui se marre de ce qui s'entend tout ce
qui s'écrit oui et bien et espérons le
en tout cas
votre costume et bien coupé n'est ce pas
zut 8 dispenser la gagner mais je les
détectives vent est votre cas ce qu'elle
dit admirable monsieur fans que c'est
monsieur du snav casimir a disparu oh
j'aime beaucoup monsieur du snob votre
couvercle pour le chef au et quant à
votre call home et oui quelle classe
comme il est très bien merlo folle mais
si là il a beaucoup de goût écoutez fait
est ce que vous vous moquez de moi tous
les deux je vous dis je voudrais pas que
casimir a disparu
du calme du calme il me reste 20 minutes
devant moi pour le retrouver un chasse
enerpart ici c'est très mauvaise foi du
tournage cela devient mieux cela sourit
chauffe cela cela bouillonne soleil
brille n'a eu
qu'à liège et uv vous avez trouvé le
gloubiboulga que j'avais préparé que
casimir mais casimiro et iwuy ou est il
un peu de patience tous les deux ayant
gelé s'il vous plaît donnez moi le chef
qui ait l'air d'un caillou monsieur 10,9
avez vous par hasard et soufflé toutes
et tous
souffler voilà mais c'est beaucoup
regardé je souffre la fumée du fumet de
gloubiboulga dans toutes les directions
y est et voilà il ya peut-être quelque
chose où la vitesse dans le casque dit
mademoiselle julie eric meurice 9
cachez-vous vite et wade belak fois le
même je vous le dis
mais enfin quel est cette délicieuse
odeur de gloubiboulga qui vous ne me
chatouiller les narines jusque dans ma
cachette
inutile le voilà au
look et l'odeur qu'il est beau
quelle merveille
au jeu je vais aller le déguster
tranquillement bien au chaud chez moi en
cachette
et voilà le tchèque a émis émis aux
bravo monsieur phal mais si vous êtes
allé mouvement baptisé joli tout ça mais
casimir a disparu une nouvelle fois nous
ne savons pas où et je les plains double
boulga haut